kim kardashian is taking a break from
the law books and heading to saturday
night live
it's a different experience for sure and
e.t has new details on how ex-kanye west
is involved i'm rolling with it a source
tells e.t quote kim and kanye are in a
great place and they always bounce ideas
off of each other and look to each other
for advice and guidance and this gig is
no exception
we have an amazing co-parenting
relationship
and
i i respect him so much kanye is of
course very familiar with the sketch
comedy show i play with the hunnids
love is the new money
that's my frequency
it's not the burner stage
play the room heal the hate the grammy
winner has performed on snl several
times over the years and here's kim
backstage when kanye was the musical
guest in 2018.
everyone tune in to snl
but now kim is making her snl hosting
debut and our source says she's quote
incredibly excited adding quote she's so
smart and such a professional she really
wants to do the best job possible and
wow everyone and make them laugh
kim is extremely funny and all her close
friends and family know that
and get this the source says quote she's
looking forward to poking fun at herself
i think you have to have a sense of
humor so yeah this is kim's first time
hosting of the show
i know right
four sisters
but impressions of the reality star well
that's a different story i'm starring in
a bunch
former cast member nasim padrod was a
frequent kim k impersonator with many of
the sketches also featuring jay pharoah
as kanye
kim's body left and then rose again
remind you of anyone
his name rhymes with jesus
the mom of four has also been sharing
her excitement for the big night on her
instagram story showcasing this
monogrammed water bottle and her
dressing room name plate and who else is
excited for saturday the snl cast i
can't speak to what everyone in the cast
feels but
heidi and i have talked and we've
decided to be honorary kardashian
sisters e.t caught up with snl's heidi
gardner and eggo wodem ahead of the
season 47 premiere and safe to say
they're thrilled to see kim try her hand
at comedy it's just exciting for us to
be part of a show where we have someone
come in who doesn't necessarily do what
we do and is so
not into what we do and then get to like
elevate them and make them look good and
make them have fun and and bring out
sides of them that people haven't
otherwise seen so we're hopeful and
excited yeah and this is kylie
kardashian and this is kestone
destiny with a k-h
[Music]